髪の毛切っとけばよかったこんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
皆さん4月の19日何の日かご存知
でしょうか
[音楽]
正解です今日はなんとあの人類史上最強の
女神小嶋陽菜様の誕生日でございます
お誕生日おめでとうございますというわけ
でこじはるさんはですね僕ちょっと語ると
長くなっちゃうんですけどもアイドルが
好きになった原因になる方でもう
根源です根源オリジン僕が高校2年生かな
高2高3ぐらいの時から初めてAKB48
というものを知りましてやっぱり人はその
推しメンだったりとか好きな人誰みたいな
話をするわけなんですけども僕はもう完全
にこじはるさんがこじはるさんがもうド
タイプでしてこんな綺麗な人が世の中にい
ていいのかそしてその人歌って踊るのか
すごい
神だということでもう何年間も崇拝してき
たわけなんですけどもで先日ですね私の
誕生日に
はじめしゃちょーお誕生日おめでとうお
めでとう
ちょっと
待ってちょっと待って
初めて誕生日にうちにプレゼントボックス
の中に入っていらっしゃってもあの
嬉しくて本当に素敵なサプライズそして
その後誕生日プレゼントもいただいたと
いうことで今回小嶋陽菜さんの誕生日と
いうことでこじはるさんがやられている
会社のお誕生日会みたいなのがあるらしい
んですけれどもそちらに私潜入させて
いただきまして誕生日プレゼントという
ことでそのものを渡すとかじゃあ俺は
足りなくてあの人への思いは
物とかお金でどうにかなるものじゃないん
ですよというわけですねはるさんといえば
この曲みたいなのが僕の中にありまして
AKB48さんのハート型ウイルスという
曲があるんですけどもそれをそれを
ダンスとか歌とかちょっと頑張ったんです
よはいありがとうございまーす
始めの歯っていうところもちょっと
はっていうだけ始めようちょっと
破裂感とかしましょうかはいお願いします
[音楽]
何が
きっかけたんだのか
[音楽]
絶対にありえない
そう思っていたのになんだか私
あなたのことが
好きみたい今日はよろしくお願いしますお
願いしますハートが飛び降りそうですね
ちゃんと踊りたくて
おります是非それにその僕ダンス全く初心
者で何も踊れないんですけど
内部的にはどんなもんなんですか
そうです
階段上がってきて
[音楽]
右足から歩き出しますその時に
ワンツー
スリーに
12121でちょっと体を
そうです
[音楽]
[拍手]
さんいる程度やったら全部ぶっ飛びます
本当に残された時間っていかに確実に
覚えれるか
顔もそうですね
胸を張るけどお腹を出さないはいマイク
むず一応完璧に踊れるし歌もしっかり歌う
ことができましたただ
本人を目の前にそれができるかどうかって
いうところがちょっとすごい不安なんです
けどもだって元だとしてもアイドルの前で
その人の歌とダンス踊るやつおるお宅で
地獄よというわけでちょっと
体の誕生日に本人の前でハート型ウイルス
を踊らせていただきたいと思います
早速そろそろ始まりますのでパーティー
会場へ行ってきますでは
[音楽]
そろそろ3人お願いしてもいいですか2人
10秒お願いします
[拍手]
[音楽]
仲良くならないけど
過去形に
なった
何も
手にさえない
私は咲いたこんな
注射を
聞かないわ
あなたのこと
になっていつか街くらい
[音楽]
おめでとうございます
[拍手]
[音楽]
おまけみたいな感じです
すごい
めっちゃ大きい油に変えるだけだとね
申し訳ないですから
[拍手]
帰りですか
[音楽]